thank you for coming to spotify tonight
and
i hope you enjoyed the beer and pizza i
know how much uh
geeks like or hate pizza
so just a quick overview i'm not going
to bore you too much with the spotify
stats but
um one thing just to kind of put out
there is that
we're pretty much uh on all different
native applications web ios
android windows mac and we're a service
origin architecture so we have on our
back end we have over 50.
it's hard to get a nail down an exact
number but it's probably closer to 60 to
80 different services
throughout we're primarily using
cassandra though there's different
elements of our system
using postgresql
cabinet and a couple different other
things we have about 7
000 servers in production right now um
that's growing quite rapidly i believe
it was closer to 6 000 six months ago
when i joined
and about half 500 engineers worldwide
so
one of the challenges that we had is how
do we package our software we
primarily are debian shop so we've used
wwe packages which works great but how
do you
solve that for python versus java versus
all the different technologies that
we're using
so what have we been doing so prior to
when i started we were actually using
debian stable packages which works great
they're awesome except for one thing
it's not really keeping up with the
state-of-the-art python development
they're always delayed they're always
behind and there's good reason for that
but sometimes you need the latest and
greatest sometimes you need that updated
package
so we started backboarding those
libraries as needed into our libraries
so we have our own demian package
repository
and um uh all the dependencies are
therefore defined in those packages our
application will list every single
dependency they need
and um that becomes a pain in the ass
when we start developing software on our
local boxes which as you can see
is a macintosh this is the quick
chart that i tried to conceptualize what
we were doing so as you can see we've
got our debian package included in
aptitude to get to our servers
we have our code coming through git
going up to our team city build servers
we also have this nasty little thing
from github backboarding code that's
already available out in pipeline so why
are we repackaging code
uh was a question and then our configs
coming through puppets so we're doing
some good things
but we're doing some kind of extra work
as well
so what's wrong with that one of the
things is
as i mentioned debbie and stable doesn't
include the latest and greatest
while they try to keep up to date as
quickly as possible
things lag and sometimes you need that
bug fix
it requires backboarding backboarding is
a hugely manual process of copying code
from the github repo or whatever
services that they're using
creating builds in our services creating
debian packages for those
and then trying to override those um in
our requirements
and it doesn't use normal python
packaging so it's really annoying as a
python developer to sit there and use
pip
or easy install if you will and then
have to transfer over to some other
system when we're actually on our
servers
we primarily use mac as our development
platform but we also have people using
linux we have people using mac uh
windows and so it's really annoying to
have to be able to find dependencies in
multiple places so that
things can work one of the things that
happened is
we've concentrated on making our live
systems
really great and we have our great
dependencies and our dummy packages
but then ramping up a new engineer is
really difficult because
we have to say look at the debian
requirements package or requirements
file
and just start installing manually on
your system and hope you get the right
version
which is not really good the other
option that i've done previously is
you have your setup py file or your
requirements text file you list all your
dependencies there then you manually
duplicate those into your w package or
have some hacky script that converts
between the two
the other big thing is rollback is not
consistent so you can roll back your
application pretty well because it's
just a demanding package but what
happens if it updated dependency
well you can snapshot if you're using
images or if you're using virtual
machines
that works great but what happens when
you just want to roll back your
application but not everything else it
might have changed so right now
the way you have to do that is look at
your deployment history
start rolling back and that takes time
the other big thing that kind of goes
under the radar but
comes back to haunt you on occasion is
that what you're testing on your server
this gets to the heart of well it worked
on my machine
which i know all of us in this room have
used more times than we care to admit
and annoys all the qa people if there's
anybody out there but
what happens is we test on our machine
with our environment with our
setup file maybe we deployed to a
continuous integration environment where
it's testing with its own
idea of what the world looks like and
then we deploy to our server which has
maybe a different look at what what
we're looking at so the idea here is
let's package up the thing that actually
is our application which is our code
all of our dependency code and see if we
can figure out a way to solve that
the other thing that we run into is if
you're installing packages directly
through debian it's installed into the
system icon which means that if you
upgrade a dependency it upgrades it for
everybody
if you're running multiple services
multiple code bases you now have to
coordinate between teams and
from a previous slide we have about 500
engineers it's pretty difficult to get
500 engineers to ever agree on anything
even in the swedish culture where
consensus is king
it's really difficult to get that many
people on board
so there must be we decided a while back
that there must be a better way to
package python code it works better in
other languages it works better
on more systems so what can we do so we
wanted to avoid duplication of effort
we wanted to increase the stability and
the repeatability so that we set up a
new server it gets set up correctly
we wanted to offer an easy rollback so
that we have a release that's bad we can
very quickly and easily really
roll that back and we wanted it to be
able to scale so
as you can imagine when you have one or
two services your dependency list is
fairly small maybe it doesn't
you have 50 60 80 services you're all of
a sudden we have
over 100 different probably closer to
two or three hundred
different packages that we're
backboarding that we have to keep and we
have to maintain
and we have to keep going with so what
do we do now so one of the things
some of my colleagues in stockholm is
they created something called dh virtual
m so the vh is for debbie and helper for
those who don't know
and virtual end we probably all know
because we probably all use it on our
systems every day
so what does it do at first it registers
itself as a debian helper and what a w
helper is is it goes through and says
and read it in is a process that happens
whenever we do a build
so just like other ones that are shipped
there's a python debian helper that will
in general try to help you deploy python
code we just register ourselves in there
we actually replace ourselves we replace
all of the other python
helpers because we don't want any
conflicts
what it does is it takes a
requirements.txt file and
bundles all of those things into a
virtual environment it builds that
virtual
environment and then it bundles that up
so what you're actually deploying is
that virtual environment which is the
exact same thing that you tested on your
server
hopefully it's the exact same thing you
tested on your ci server for unit
testing
and it's the exact same thing that
you're going to deploy so there's a
repeatability
um it deploys it currently into the user
share python
although that's configurable and pretty
easily changed in the code
one caveat is it still requires that
your native code be
compiled and included with debian
because
pip has its limitations it's not going
to be able to install
a compile a precompiled version onto
your server and compile it there so what
happens there is
since our build servers may not be the
exact same operating system architecture
as
our deployment system we don't want to
deploy any of those
native code because we might have
conflicts with the operating system
and what do you do how do you do it well
you just include the following and
you're doing rules and you're done
sounds easy right so going back to our
previous picture
our new deployment process doesn't look
that much simpler
but one thing to notice is that this
area here is a lot easier because we're
pulling from pipe we no longer have that
back porting
going into our git repository we no
longer have to keep that up and the
entire manual process is completely
removed
we now rely on the maintainers of the
libraries to decide
when and if we should be updating and
when what's available
and the reason there's a line into the
team city is that's all being pulled
into a virtual environment on our build
servers
so first of all it worked which was
which was kind of
uh eye opening uh we have not converted
all
of our python applications over to this
yet we're still in the process of that
but we have an example where we have an
application using sentry for log
processing
and one of the things that we had to do
is all we had to do to do this
so that it works on your development
system and it works on our
servers is include our dependencies in
the requirements txt
which we're all familiar with for those
of you
um using uh debian you're probably
familiar with
uh defining dependencies and debian so
here instead of having a large list with
everything we just have a couple of
things
where we require python required virtual
environment a couple of different other
packages of support
some of the things that century needs
for ssl
and logins
and then inside our rules file we just
specify
this is the only required line which
says use use the debian helper for uh
virtual end here we're actually
overriding
where we're driving packages from so in
this case we're grabbing it from our
local mirror i
hid the host name but this is just our
local mirror pi pi as opposed to
defaulting the pipeline
previously for a few people in the
audience who knew me in a previous life
i worked at amplify and we did a very
similar thing but we used rpms there
because we were
using centos and red hat systems and we
did a very similar thing where we
built the package we installed it
we installed all of our dependencies and
then we just
packaged it with this relocatable so the
authors of virtualenv are probably going
to kill me for this because
if you read the documentation it's very
clear that relocatable is an
experimental tag that may be removed in
future versions
but it works and what it does is it just
removes all your absolute paths
and replaces them with relative paths
so one of the things is what what does
this give us versus we're no longer
stuck in stable so we weren't stuck on
staple before but for those of you that
don't want to go through the process of
backboarding
you might be we no longer have to do
that manual process of backboarding
we have code isolation so one of the
other things that you
previously i talked about was the fact
that if we have multiple things running
on the same server we either have to
come to an agreement about an upgrade or
we don't upgrade and
odds are we don't upgrade and we
probably all have code out there that
has a three-year-old dependency that
is buggy as hell and we just haven't
updated so here now each application is
using its own virtual environment and
therefore we can upgrade just as we
would on our development machine
uh we also have a single package
rollback because outside of those
uh those native library dependencies
everything's within our package
including
whatever packages we're using whether
that's the ldap package whether that's
uh django or whether that's flask or
whatever system that we're using it's
all in our code
it's all in our package and all we have
to do is roll back that one thing
uh development and deployment systems
are now the same so the thing that i
test on my server is as close as
possible to the thing that i'm going to
actually deploy to the server the thing
i run unit tests on
in our ci environment is the exact same
package that we're deploying
so it's great but you know if you notice
we still have that one caveat which is
native applications or native libraries
are still being deployed
by debian dependencies which means that
there's a deployment time dependency
resolution which is
really really terrible there's ways to
solve that and we're starting to
investigate those
next but to be honest we're not 100 sure
where we're going with that
one of the things we do at spotify is to
try to experiment with everything and
figure out what works
um one thing that is that dh virtual end
as of two days ago is now on the debian
unstable repositories
so still getting to that fact that we we
applied for
inclusion i believe three or four months
ago and they're still fighting to get
into that stable branch um kind of makes
a point for me
still requires managing native
dependencies locally which is bad
because that's one more every time we do
a deployment
resolution we're probably encouraging
a problem because unless we're actually
going to be
hard coding in every single specific
version number which creates its own
issues
what we're saying is when i deploy in my
ci environment
i'm going to test one thing when i
deploy my
production environment even if it's
hours later i'm probably going to deploy
a different version because something
updated something changed
we're also experimenting with containers
um so there's some people
and working with us in spotify where
we're actually saying okay let's try to
take this to the next level now that we
have virtual environments for our python
code
we still have issues with java we still
have issues with um
with some of the c code and some of the
other pieces of technology that we're
using
let's start deploying this stuff as
containers so
we're actually bundling up those native
library dependencies now
and trying to deploy those using docker
and stay tuned i hope that we'll
continue iterating on this i hope we
continue
pushing forward on how to deploy this
python code and that we can kind of
refine it a little bit more
just a little thanks to yurky and jim
who work out of our
stockholm office who actually wrote most
of this code and
promoted it and wrote the uh the blog
post or the white paper
down at the bottom and so um
thanks to them for actually writing this
and taking the time out of their data
and making things a little bit more sane
questions
how do you deal with that
in those cases where we actually need
that kind of leading edge
we would probably still look at
backboarding and actually we have our
own pipeline server
both that we mirror ipi and we also have
our own library or our own repository
for our code
and most likely what we would do there
is do kind of a manual step
to to do that but if that continues to
become a problem we'll have to that'll
be the next challenge that we'll have to
solve
that
um when you're deploying these packages
uh on virtual end
in production are you seeing any
significant differences
in performance
sofa i don't think this is working
we haven't noticed anything to be honest
one of the things that we've looked at
um and i've done at a previous position
is we ran low testing against uh virtual
environment versus native
environment we noticed no difference the
reason being is kind of
the way virtual environments is really
working is it's just using pointers for
the most part
so at the end of the day following a
point or having a direct link
to the file isn't going to give you much
difference we
in terms of packaging and the actual
build process we took a little hit in
the beginning because
it takes a little longer to download all
the packages and bundle them up than it
would because you end up with a larger
artifact
than you do uh just bundling your code
and doing a deployment resolution
but for at the end of the day we decided
that this space was cheap and we'll just
throw that off the window
and go with reliability
you mentioned you had 7 000 servers i
assume that's in production or is that
globally
with production dev uh globally
or i mean production sorry okay you also
mentioned
that your build servers are different
from your target servers um
is there some level of typical debt that
has this
uh situation or is it just a question of
you have regional differences that
require you to have
uh to perform mobile bills that it
because again from my perspective it
just doesn't seem to make
a lot of sense i'll wait for them
i feel like i should be doing a dance
team um that is a very good question and
it's technical that so most of the
we actually have very similar systems so
all of our systems are debian
all of our all of our systems are
running very similar software
but because we're running our build
systems here and we're running our
production systems in different data
centers around the world
there is a lag sometimes when we're
updating packages that lag should be
pretty small
but also i think some of it is just
literally tech debt from dependency
management
you know looking in the past you know
the more complex system you make
the more likely it is that people are
going to take shortcuts and so i think
if you look at some of our systems
they're really clean they're really
modern and they're really really nailed
down
if you look at some of our older systems
where we were doing deployment time
resolution we were deploying the
packages that made sense at that
particular time in history so you have
slight differences between servers even
which is not good which is
something that we're cleaning up and
trying to get a handle on and you have
you have problems with the the fact that
currently
our build system has a certain set of
dependencies installed so that it can
actually do its tests
outside of the ones where we're actually
doing virtual environments
before that you were deploying a version
of ldap for example to
our production services that everybody
had to work against
because we had one centralized build
system so as we move more to virtual
environments in general
that will go away because we'll start
having our isolation both on
our ci environment as well as in our
production service
oh we got two bikes oh yeah
to unit okay
zero
how do you handle security updates since
these are
essentially statically compiled packages
so it depends if it's a if it's a
security update that's part of the
native dependencies that would be
something that we would uh take
in inventory of our debian packages and
actually start updating those
those dependencies if it's in the python
code it's as simple as
actually working with the squad so the
way we work here
is pretty much independent teams that we
try to treat as much as possible as
many startups so that we can actually
get the agility at that level
and each team owns a certain portion of
the functionality so each team is
actually entrusted to work with with our
security team to make sure that their
applications are up to date
and if they aren't and if there is a
security hole that they update
either whether it's their code or
whether it's a dependency and update on
an ongoing basis
since all of the code is actually owned
by a particular team
we can kind of have that kind of
ownership to push those sorts of things
forward as well as new feature work as
well as new bug fixes and whatnot good
do you have to rebuild all your virtual
one packages
for that new stable version
so if we're talking about new stable
version of the debian packages no unless
it's a new version of one of the core
dependencies like
uh the virtual end for example if
there's an update to that yes we would
we would do it there if it's a
dependency that's in the pipeline code
we would run our new building we're
continuously running those builds as we
change code
in on timers as well and we would just
get those updates as we go
depending on how we defined our our
dependency flags
if we're tied to a specific version it
becomes a manual process which we all
know
probably doesn't happen um if it's a
open-ended version
and you have a really good ci
environment you have a really good
continuous delivery model
then you're constantly testing against
those newest versions of latest and
greatest and you're getting all those
fixes
not for free but for much cheaper than
you would otherwise
awesome sweet thanks so much chris
okay